what's going on guys we're gonna watch
the trailer for peacemaker today
get it
we're invisible you can't see us
that was a stupid bit
we could have just done that john cena
saved us a whole bunch of time guys
we're gonna watch the official trailer
for peacemaker i hope this is visible we
didn't cover the last one because hbo
max has this incredible habit of
blocking us on mobile but we're gonna
give this one a shot because we're
genuinely interested in the show and
we're hoping to have time to cover it uh
come january i loved the suicide squad
and john cena impressed the hell out of
both of us with that film let's see what
they got today
[Music]
have you ever heard of a guy named
peacemaker no
he is a trained killer
we've got trouble with that maniac
go what are you waiting for
back there
dude that without stealing its soul
well it's eyes
look they got real eagle
that's a kind of rough go from haley dad
you don't say somebody shot me a
building fell on me you let somebody
shoot you invited me
you let somebody shoot you i thought you
were in prison for life i worked for the
government post office you that you're
like a person to deliver mail i don't
know it was the first government job i
could think of i killed people for him
okay
this task force doesn't officially exist
which leaves us on our own we call our
targets butterflies they are a serious
threat to the safety of american
citizens
there's something weird going on you
think me and vigilante are too stupid to
notice hey everyone which one's me and
which one's easily okay you're half
right but you score 50 of the test at
school what do you get
my bag it's for dorks
this guy's a clown oh something about
him that's
sad oh yeah absolutely inside peacemaker
take him out even the kids yes terminate
them immediately
take
he told me to kill kids he didn't say
why
because right now the world needs a son
of a [ __ ]
and you're the only one i got but will
it bring peace
not to his heart
no matter how many men women and
children you needed to kill to get it he
did say that yeah it was one of the most
famous lines from the last trailer i'm
having feelings about things
[Music]
dad maybe i'm a grower
not a shower what an individual you
don't like and then
you learn to like you're comparing
yourself to a chode
not a bad way your dad is not a good man
he's still family my advice cut it out
with the introspection the mind is a den
of scorpions better left running from
not towards
[Applause]
[Music]
two jerks and costumes and a couple of
rejects
rejects like a real team out there
what the hell is that it's a grenade i
tied to a russian tank shell why not
just the grenade grenade blows up like
two people how many people
i don't know i invented it this morning
what
eat peace [ __ ]
[Laughter]
damn
i like the updated mask a lot yeah
the red eyes
red glasses not the eyes but the
like this the
window to the goggles yeah
it's the snyder verse everybody's gotta
have goggles or offshoots of the snyder
you know what i mean don't trigger
people i'm sorry
i didn't mean it it's the james
gunniverse now now it is i like the
approach that this show is taking with
being able to like break down evolve
peacemaker for where he saw a song in
the suicide squad movie i find it to be
a very interesting choice overall of how
this project came to be this was
announced before the suicide squad even
got released and so that just showed the
amount of faith they had in this
character and the future of this project
i don't know the last time have we seen
something like this that i'm not just
recalling where a movie comes out and
then a few months later a show that is a
spin-off of one of the characters in
that ensemble gets released like so soon
after i don't i don't know the last time
we saw something absolutely feels like
something very much of this moment in
moving in television history for sure
because they're doing that with the
batman coming up where there's going to
be spin-offs of that that are supposed
to be hbo max shows as well so this is
like a new kind of plan that they're
doing like yeah do we have like marvel
where the shows are connected it's like
this is a completely different terrain
where this character is introduced in a
movie main supporting character and now
has their own show so soon after yeah
yeah it's almost like you're starting
the suicide squad universe right now
it's a great continuation of it where
there was such a major conflict that
came in a hand with peacemaker in that
movie to then take his character start
to really humanize him to the point
where you start to deconstruct just why
he has the personality that he has i
love like the stuff that interested me
the most was actually not the missions
and everything like i'm sure that's all
going to be fun it's going to feel very
james gunn ass and it's going to be a
lot of what we sort of got from the
suicide squad ensemble bantering ah you
sound kind of stupid there's cool action
it's violent it's rollicking but yeah
there'll be plenty of different jokes
yeah that all seems familiar it's gonna
be really entertaining and the show
needs to have that and i want that in
there the new stuff that we were getting
was mainly in terms of humanizing him
and you know asking the question of how
much does this guy actually repress like
we laugh at him quite a bit but now
let's really go into his soul and see
what's going underneath the surface and
like explore his relationship with his
father this is why he is the way he is
and probably a lot of this seems to be
directed towards i want to satisfy daddy
and i love that we're gonna it really
seems like we're gonna be dealing with
that a lot and it's gonna be the
emotional through line throughout this
series and it's not just something
they're touching on it's something
they're really going to explore you
don't get robert patrick just to touch
on that no no no yeah and like that was
yeah the most probably exciting thing to
me about this trailer is just the
prospect of you know john cena and
robert patrick acting off each other and
what that relationship can become
because you know i trust james gunn's
sensibility enough to know that yeah
like we're gonna get a lot of like the
fun and enjoyable stuff that you
probably would expect from that dynamic
but we're also probably going to get a
lot of things that are surprisingly true
or heartfelt or you know emotionally
hard or raw in some way it's like taking
all the main beats of peacemaker with
the whole crack in the uh you know early
scenes of suicide squad about how like
oh you know your origin story is just
like a blood sports origin story you
know you both had this hard-assed dad
and now going in to deconstruct that and
then also take the main conflict coming
from peacemaker and the suicide squad
and turning that inward a very poignant
kind of way to approach this that seems
to support the natural way that james
gunn has at least said he kind of came
up with this idea and so yeah i felt
that enthusiasm watching this trailer
and i am always rooting for john cena's
acting to get that much better and it
seems like right yeah it would probably
be pretty great here and then also too i
like the ensemble in the suicide squad
so i'm happy to see them back and that
also grounds it in like it still looks
like it's going to get kind of big and
kind of broad but you feel like yeah
we've got this small team and we're
doing these down and dirty missions and
we're kind of on the run not necessarily
because working with government but you
know we got to keep this like
clandestine in a way you know at least
the core of our operation and so yeah it
just seems like this is the right size
and i'm really interested to see how it
all plays out i'm sure it's going to be
a damn fine show this seems like the
kind of show where it has so many
different emotions to deal with like a
james gun
property ultimately is that it's gonna
have a lot of heart it's gonna be really
funny probably irreverent but also it's
gonna be able to really get you in the
feels in unexpected ways but also excite
you and shock you yeah and his chemistry
with vigilante looks really fun and i
mean that's a you know kind of you know
it's a well-worn gag of like the guy
with this awesome costume who has kind
of a dorky voice but i don't know like
i'm i'm really excited to see how how
that kind of comes to life too because
from the moments we got here like that's
the character i'm most excited to meet
it looks like a scene stealer yeah and
this has easily been john cena's best
role he's ever done 100
so i'm excited to see it explored the
show
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below you can subscribe click that bell
hit that like button and hey
fox fox you're the biggest badass at our
patreon so i figured we should shout you
out with the biggest badass currently
coming from the dc universe i feel like
you know if i wanted to get jacked you
could probably help me achieve that but
you would also do it with your signature
style and flair because you much like a
james gunn movie are thoughtful but you
also know how to get a good jab in
you've got a good sense of wit and i
very much admire that about you and it
warms my heart and soul every time you
pop up in one of our comments just to
leave one of your rambles believe me i
see them and i love them so i hope
you're doing well hope you're having a
good holiday season and uh even though
we can't see you
we're thinking about you
much love
you know i've only seen you do this on
camera
i've never once
ever you're just not looking hard enough
seeing you do it in real life every time
you turn your back
[Music]